but I go can I just try another one that
moment comes and I turn round and all my
army are literally like this to find him
of the Opera I was very surprised that I
was picked for that role because I used
to sing in a rock band when I was a law
student Joel Schumacher called my agent
and said can Jerry sing my agent said I
can sing bad or if you can sing that so
it went from me going for my first ever
singing lesson and singing to the
professor of music from Royal Academy of
Music in London and I said look just
tell me am I wasting my time I don't
wanna make a fool of myself and we
finished and she said you can absolutely
do this you need to put in a lot of work
you need to learn the rules but you can
do this you know so that's all I needed
to hear there's so many times I'd just
be sitting there going how the hell did
I get here this is awesome I can't even
sing I love the opportunity to try
different things and hopefully surprise
people and maybe prove them wrong so
sometimes when people have a lot to say
you go okay look just kind of ups the
ante in a way 300
I wanted out rolls so badly and I
remember being told by the producers we
want you but we're scared to go to alan
horne who's the president of Warner
Brothers just in case he doesn't want
you and then it's gonna hurt our movie
we're gonna look stupid so we know you
know Alan by the way through the Phantom
of the Opera so why don't you call him
and I called him I was I would say Kings
Road Cafe and I said hollandaise Jerry
Butler he said how are you Jerry I know
why you're calling and let me tell you
there's a process and you have to be
nominated by them and I wanted to say I
have been they're the ones that told me
to call you but I didn't say that but I
pushed and if these little moments in
your life that make all the difference
but I said I know but and he said I'll
tell you what come in for a coffee and I
went for a coffee and I had my whole
speech prepared saying everything I've
done in my life has led to this moment
to play this man and I promise you if
you give me this chance I will not let
you down and he did give me the chance
and the rest of it was me trying to hold
up my end of the bargain take on this
character do Leonidas proud do the
Spartans proud do our horn proud that
led me to this incredibly tunnel
visioned kind of preparation and focus
just die hard I trained every hour I
could sounds weird but I would literally
channel Leonidas I we don't just do
these meditations where I would feel him
coming into me through time through some
kind of weird portal like just coming
into my body and then I can have felt if
he's in me then I'm just trusting that
this is transmitting Spartans never
retreat Spartans never surrender there's
a big fight sequence when I had
rehearsed us for months I know in the
day we were doing it was the first big
action sequence we were shooting in the
movie and there was a camera rig that it
three different cameras had never been
used before something was not going
right so it was one o'clock in the
afternoon we hadn't shot anything they
basically said to my stunt double you
get off and get ready to go because we
don't have time for failure thing eight
was killing me and like I've done all
this I've trained and trained and
trained and this is my big moment
and I wanted to scream and shout but I
did and Tim Connolly my stunt double
who's also
my father to the young me in the movie
he could see and he's like look that's
here he says I don't want to do this
either I want you to do this
he said so get up and just start
practicing with me just so the director
can see you kind of you're good at this
so I get up and I'm doing my moves and I
see Zack looking over and then I see him
speak to somebody and they go okay let's
try one Jerry why don't you try it and I
did it and it was amazing and I finished
maybe that biggest buzz I ever had my
career is when I finish and I clicked
the sword with a guide on it
and I look up and everybody started
about the whole crew they're like just
exploded and all the stuntmen jumped off
everybody exploded
this is sparta which has obviously
become quite an iconic line I had done
quite a few takes and most of them work
this is sparta this part process and
part insecurity maybe but I go can I
just try another one he goes ok
ok go for it and that moment comes and I
turn and oh my army are literally like
this and I go up to zai and I go that
was too much how that was too much ego
yeah but it was awesome
yes
I trained the dragon How to Train Your
Dragon was surprisingly one of the most
special experiences I ever had it was
just fun to go in and play this big loud
ignorant Viking who's just surprises
people with the heart they had cameras
everywhere and I remember thinking why
you go cameras in oh it's just my voice
and then my main animator his name was
Christoph one day showed me how they
animated so it doesn't seem where I'm
kind of saying well I thought it was
there you are thank you God and yet I
didn't I didn't realize I was moving so
much but that was me doing all of this
and then you see me in the movie and
it's literally animated just like I was
there God almost gave up on you but here
we are and ties you into something so
much you know you realize okay it's not
just my voice there's a bit more that
I'm that I'm giving to that he could
crush meant this level forest tamed seas
even as a boy I knew what I was what I
had to become hiccup is not that boy and
it's very funny because nowadays people
introduce you know they say the kids
this is Stoick from How to Train Your
Dragon and you see the kids like us and
then I go Harry how are you we're gonna
go and chase dragons and it's so awesome
I love it Danna Thieves
I read den of thieves back in 2012 and
was one of my favorite scripts letters
so clever but we couldn't get it made it
was a very hard movie to get maybe
because it wasn't cheap and Christian
had never directed anything before
there often came these conversations
which were maybe it's time to move on by
this point I've become very close with
Christian and I also loved this movie
finally we pulled the money together and
then we're making the movie but I felt
this big pressure because for years I
just have dinners and lunches with
Christian and he would talk about being
his big Knicks this big Knicks this big
next this and then we go to start the
movie and I like she he's told me a lot
about big Nick I hope I remember how
here is big Nick and one time we're not
a restaurant it's like a Benihana or
something there's a plate which i think
is sushi and while he's talking I'm like
this on the alternate going this is
really chewy sushi but I'm like my god
this is how big Nick whatand you're
talking about big Nick I finished the
plate and he's like by the way that's
raw chicken and that was basically big
Nick right let me ask you this do we
look like the types who arrest you put
you in handcuffs drag you down to the
station
hmm I'm asking you a question
no right we just shoot you and it was
also the best time I had with other
actors were also great friends and all
my movies I've never had so much love
for the people that I worked with and
you know we really tried to keep that or
lack of bond yes I love you yeah play a
guy called Jerry so already was a good
start Jerry Kennedy who is - a lot of
people a lot of women that perfect guy
great sense of humor loves the crap out
of his wife I said you know what in this
movie I'm not gonna think about like
like Jerry does I'm not gonna think
about myself I'm gonna think about
everybody else and it was amazing
how incredible that was it took me out
my own head and not to be honest was the
story of that movie everybody was making
it for the right reasons and everybody
had their own personal story it was
Richard it was his best friend who died
of a heart attack it was a director and
then to the producer Molly her sister
who died of cancer and you know this was
her story is a
and that was about ten times through
this movie it was their own personal
stories I know what I want because I
have it in my hands right now do you
know what you want you better tell me
now if I'm not it one to work with
Hilary Swank who's incredible and for me
to get a chance to because I so often
play Americans to me the Scots in the
Irish was so similar my whole family's
most of my family are Irish to have a
chance to bring on that kind of Irish
character in such a well written script
was just I mean I mean I really had such
a great time filming I mean even today
people come and they go they start
people often start crying as they tell
me about how much they cry during that
movie beautifully written and
beautifully directed by Richard law
abiding citizen that's the first movie
that I produced but I was always playing
in the other room I was playing the hero
the cop but I kept saying I can't want
to play this guy but all my guys kept
saying no no just stick to the hero
stick to the hero and we were trying to
find somebody to play Clyde Shelton and
we offered it to Jamie Foxx and Jamie
being the cocky that he is said nope
don't buy deeply klaich own but I'll
play his role we were all on the call
Jamie wasn't in the car but all the
producers and I said okay let's do it
so basically we swap roles and I'm so
glad I now can't imagine that movie any
other way counselor you might want to
cancel your 12:30 lunch with Judge
Roberts excuse me
in fact you might want to cancel the
rest of the week because you're going to
be busy sit down I always felt there
came a certain point in the movie where
the audience returned against client
when he starts killing innocent people
but it was amazing the Vengeance that
were in an audience who were like no he
was so badly wronged and because you did
feel his humanity and because Jamie did
push it in the other direction it was
amazing how far my character could go
and people still wanted to win and
wanting to get away with it
that's not how I imagined it but I can
love that that's how it turned out but
it was an interesting psychological
study on humanity as a whole
the ugly truth I was making a movie
called gamer every night at dinner we'd
all be having dinner and I'd tell I have
perhaps a hundred and fifty thousand
jokes I grew up in that culture and I
still write them down so I tell jokes
jokes you and then Tom and Gary would go
over the truth and what is likely truth
and they kept going ugly truth and
winking and I'm thinking what is ugly
truth and I was assuming that it was
some movie like gamer and then he sent
me the script are you kidding me I'm
gonna get to say this I had the role but
I says can i audition for this role in
an American accent so I went in and I
did three of my biggest scenes in an
American accent I'm the UN yeah you're
American
suddenly I'm working with Katie Heigl I
was madly in love with Katie I go and
she just made our movie with Seth Rogen
which is one of my favorite movies of
all time but now we're on set together
and I'm like how how is this happening
if you want it to work out with this guy
then you'll listen to me and you do
exactly as I say you've probably already
done irreparable damage with your psycho
aggressive control freak phone call it
might even be too late and if you do
salvage the situation you never be more
than a be his desperate neighbor it's
such a blast making that playing that
guy it's just fun Olympus has fallen and
twine and I had been working on a lot of
different projects and I took it to him
and said what about this thinking he'd
say no but he's like you know what this
is fun let's let's do this
I love developing scripts and he loves
making movies and he shot the hell out
of this and but even then I wasn't sure
know how this is going to turn out and
it just turned out in terms of the
ultimate popcorn movie you know super
fun in-your-face inspiring you know
heroic
London has fallen for every movie we try
to find a different take so London we
made it more international we could be
bringing into Japanese the Canadians but
again finding a way how do you make a
city unworkable not just an area but
create a situation where in a whole city
nobody can move and you got to get a
president out of there and he's like a
hunted animal Angel is falling and then
in this one we've gone in a completely
different direction because you thought
well it can't really be a city or a
white house so we turned to internet and
itself and made it about the very man
who's gone through all this I feel like
you get to know him just like I've
gotten to know him more you get to know
him more in his challenges and his
weaknesses and his vulnerabilities but
yet again through all of that his
tenacity and his brutality and his need
to be of service and and get the job
done I said this earlier today it's like
he could be run over by a truck but if
there's one born unbroken he's gonna
keep coming back he's never gonna stop
that serves me well I take a lot out of
that for me in my life because I've been
through a lot
coming into this movie I felt like I was
kind of in Mike's shoes which funnily
enough made the performance ten times
more difficult but 10 times more easy in
other ways because I was where he was I
think that it's not only am I getting to
know him I seem to be becoming him
[Music]